in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for October 9th on which we commemorate
Saint Andronikos and Athanasia, his wife.
Saint Andronikos lived during the 6th century in Antioch, where he was a prosperous banker.
He and his wife Athanasia were devout and virtuous, and some time after their marriage
decided to divide all they had into three parts.
The first part, they distributed unstintedly to the poor.
The second, they lent without usually to folk they knew were in need.
And the third part, they kept to live on themselves.
They had two children, a boy and a girl whom they brought up in piety and with love for the poor.
But when they reached the age of twelve, both of them suddenly died.
Andronikos was neither cast down nor despairing, but applying to his own case the words of Job.
He said, Naked I came from my mother's womb, and Naked shall I return.
The Lord gave and the Lord has taken away. Blessed be the name of the Lord.
But his wife was utterly distraught, and when the funeral service was over,
she refused to leave the Church of St. Julian and said weeping.
Let me to die here, and be buried with my children.
After nightfall, when she was still there alone in the Church,
the holy martyr Julian appeared to her in the guise of an unknown monk.
He changed her tears of despair into tears of joy by showing her that God had taken her children
from this transitory life in order to welcome them the sooner, to wear the blessed dwell.
When they considered these things, the parents themselves decided to leave this world,
even before they died, by entering upon the monastic life.
They gave away what remained of their goods and set out on foot for Jerusalem.
Having left behind possessions, country, and acquaintance,
they lifted up their eyes to heaven as they made their way and cried out.
Lord, Thou saidst to Abraham and Sarah, go from your country and your kindred
and from your father's house to the land that I will show you.
Direct us in thy fear and shut not the door of thy kingdom against us.
They visited the holy places and met many of the holy ascetics who lived in Palestine.
God did not let them remain there but brought them into Egypt to renown Abad Daniel.
He sent Athanasia to the women's monastery founded by Saint Pacomios at Taberneses
and kept Andronikos by him as a disciple. After 12 years in obedience and practice of the Holy
Evangelic virtues, Andronikos received the blessing of his spiritual father to visit the holy
places once again. On the way, as he was resting in the shade of a tree, he encountered his wife
Athanasia. He did not know it was she for she was dressed as a man and named Athanasius.
Besides, her 12-year ascetic struggle had altered her face which was now dark like an Ethiopians
and beyond recognition. They exchanged a few words and agreed to make their way to Jerusalem
in company but as Athanasia insisted without speaking anymore. And so they reached their goal,
worshipped at the holy places and returned to Egypt together.
When they reached Alexandria, Athanasia broke the silence and suggested that they share a cell
and spend the rest of their days together in silence and unceasing prayer. Andronikos set out to ask
the blessing of Abad Daniel. When he told his spiritual father how he had spent the entire time
of his pilgrimage with Athanasia in complete silence, the Abad gave his blessing, saying,
dwell in this way with your brother for he has attained a high degree of virtue such as a true
monk ought to have. So Andronikos went back to Athanasia and remained with her for 12 years with never
a suspicion that his mysterious companion might be his wife. Abad Daniel often visited them to
encourage them in their ascetic struggle and to give them councils for the discernment of thoughts.
As he was returning from one of these visits, Andronikos came running after the elder to bring him back
for Athanasia had suddenly fallen ill and was getting ready to depart to the Lord.
She communicated in the holy mysteries and fell asleep in peace, leaving beside her a note in which
she revealed her secret. When he learned not only that Athanasios was a woman, but that she was also
Andronikos' wife, Abad Daniel was able to form a just estimate of the struggle beyond human endurance
of this saintly woman to remain as a stranger over so many years at her husband's side.
Summoned by the elder, all the monks of the region came to her funeral in white
Raymond, bearing palms to signify not sorrow at a death, but rejoicing at the triumph of this
athlete of piety. Athanasia proved herself possessed of the patience of the martyrs and departed
this life triumphant over the flesh, the world and the prince of this world. For she had defied
love of God not only the passions that are contrary to nature, but the natural affections as well.
Andronikos remained alone in their cell for only a short time. He gave thanks to God for having
provided him with such a companion, fell ill and joined Athanasia in the mansions of the righteous
through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.